Mike good morning walk us through this
new rule how is it put into play well an
expansion of replay was necessary in the
aftermath of the NFC Championship game
there has been talk about expanding
replays for pass interference roughing
the passer and illegal contact with
defenseless players but at the end of
the day the coaches got together and
pushed and pushed and pushed for change
there was an element among ownership
that did not want the change that
believed that would happen in the Rams
Saints game was a 100-year storm that
wasn't going to happen again for another
hundred years but the coaches engineered
this process and got the owners on the
same page and now what we have is pass
interference whether called or not
called offensive or defensive will be
subject to replay review like any other
thing that is subject to replay review
coach's challenge in the normal course
of the game buthe review triggered in
the final two minutes of the game or in
overtime and presumably on scoring plays
as well they haven't specifically said
that but I assume that that's exactly
how it will work and now if there is an
egregious violation it's got to be
egregious you know they call it a
judgement call the pass interference
sometimes involves a very poor exercise
of judgment and we all see it just like
we saw it in that ran Saints game so now
there's a way to fix what happened in
that game and most importantly to
prevent it from happening again okay is
egregious your word or is that the NFL's
word because that's I mean that's open
to interpretation of what's egregious
well egregious is my word but that's an
interpretation of the standard that the
NFL uses for replay review it has to be
a clear and obvious error based upon the
available visual evidence and we've
heard different labels applied over the
years indisputable visual evidence and
etc they've tried to simplify that to
clear and obvious that's the standard
we've heard in recent years but you know
it's a guy getting wiped out before the
ball arrives you know that's the kind of
clear and obvious that we're looking for
and I think we'll find out in practice
that they're not going to overturn these
calls where there's hand fighting or
ticky tack or something that it isn't
clear and obvious and look it's going to
be for the league office to implement it
it's going to be thrown out River on
who still has the authority to make
these decisions to come up with a
standard approach but I think the NFL
and we saw it last year with the catch
rule the NFL became very vigilant in
only overturning calls if there was
clear and obvious visual evidence and I
think that's what's gonna be required
here all right then take me through how
we would use this rule this year last
year with the Saints so that play
happens there's pass interference clear
pass interference and there is no flag
who initiates the review well if it was
more than two minutes left in the game
and I frankly can't recall whether or
not it was more than two minutes less
but you have to have a red flag
available we'd have to have a timeout
available if there was more than two
minutes left in the game so you could
challenge that if it's less than two
minutes then what happens is the replay
assistant would hit the button and
trigger the process and it would have
been overturned because it was clear
after further review that nikhyl Roby
Coleman wiped out Tommy Lee Lewis before
the ball got there that's the kind of
play that would be overturned but again
if it's more than two minutes left in
the game you've got to have a red flag
left you've got to have a timeout to
burn if you get it wrong if it's less
than two minutes or if it's in overtime
then you automatically get that
consideration and are you going to have
somebody looking at review replay in the
stadium or is it going to be sort of in
you know the Central Intelligence office
of the NFL you've always got the replay
assistant Dan who is in the stadium who
makes that initial call to trigger the
process when it doesn't fall within
those situations where a coach can throw
the red challenge fly but the final
decision will continue to be made by
either our River Run or one of his
lieutenants at the league office they've
got two or three guys there who can do
it because one o'clock Eastern on a
Sunday when there's nine or ten games
going on there's a chance there's going
to be two or three of these reviews at
once but it's still going to be a
decision made at the league office yeah
Paulie just told me that it was under
two minutes so that would have had to
have come from the replay booth not Sean
Payton could have been screaming and
yelling and kicking and it didn't matter
it had to come from that the replay
booth official what would growing don't
you think it would I think it would and
I mean because when I saw that in real
time my first reaction was oh that's too
close that's not passing or transit and
they show a review of a replay on it's
like oh my god
it's clearly past interference I mean I
think if this mechanism was in place
that that ruling would have been
overturned and it would have been past
interference first and goal for the
Saints inside the five yeah what what
problems do you see with this well I
mean the Hail Mary is the one that most
people are already pointing to because
now all you have to do is fire the ball
down the field if you know you're down
by one score or less in the final
moments of the game you just heave it up
for grabs and you hope that that maybe
there's going to be some sort of
evidence that someone got got wiped out
before the ball came and I think back to
the filme replay from 2012 between the
Seahawks and the Packers the one that
ended the lockout of the officials
because there was clear pass
interference by gold and tape before he
caught that pass but you know what if it
is clear it should be overturned
and they can worry all they want about
pass interference on a Hail Mary but if
if it's there to address clear and
obvious errors then so be it then we all
want to have satisfaction that these
games are being decided by the players
not by bad calls from the officials and
Dan this is such a critical thing the
NFL did because there's more and more
states have legalized gambling new more
and more politicians are going to get
involved when there are these
controversies they're gonna set how
about my constituents who are waging
their hard-earned wagering their
hard-earned money on these games we want
this to all be on the up-and-up and we
don't like these officiating flaws that
can lead to corruption and another Tim
Donaghy type of a situation so I think
it was smart spin I thought to get ahead
of this as we get you know toward a
dozen states and there's going to be 20
there's going to be 32 degrees 42 have
legalized gambling in the coming years
he's Mike Florio co-host of pro football
talk live on the NBC Sports Network
joining us Dan Patrick show let me
switch topics here if Ken Robert Kraft
be put on the commissioners exempt list
well the Commission is exempt list it's
a great question Dan it's only available
for certain types of violations of the
personal conduct policy and they are all
premise on some act of violence and
that's the way the personal conduct
policy was written that's the way it was
revised back in 2014 after Ray Rice Greg
Hardy Adrian Peters
and when the NFL realized there are
certain situations where innocent until
proven guilty goes out the window we
have to take these guys off the field
even though they're being paid we don't
want these guys out there where people
see them where broadcaster's talk about
them so they go on the commissioner
exempt list but it's all based upon some
sort of crime some sort of allegation of
violence of sexual assault of something
where there is a victim who has been
violated in some way and the
Commissioner doesn't have that power for
any other type of violation he wouldn't
have that power even if it would apply
to an owner and I think it only applies
to players but even if it would apply to
an owner that power to be placed on the
commissioner to exempt list wouldn't
apply based upon the charges that Robert
Kraft is facing if you were one of
Robert Kraft's lawyers what would you be
looking at now to help your client have
these charges dropped well there's an
issue with the court order that allowed
the video surveillance and that far just
wrote something about this in the last
hour PFT apparently the search warrant
application asked for permission to
monitor and record in those massage
rooms and the court order only says
monitor not record that's a technicality
but you know what if they violated the
extent of the court order that was
available for these activities that's
the kind of thing it becomes a problem
the traffic stop which was a clear
pretext to get Robert crafts
identification when he left that spa the
first time if that traffic stop has any
flaw to it that gets thrown out you
can't identify Robert craft on the video
case goes away that way and really the
fundamental thing is this Dan without
getting into a full continuing legal
education seminar here solicitation of
prostitution requires evidence that
there was advance solicitation that's
why typically a guy gets busted when
there's an undercover officer who is
there to hear him say I will give you
money for sex
there's no evidence like that here I
don't know how you prove the basic
element of solicitation just based upon
a video of what happened you need to
have some sort of audio or someone who
can testify that the person who's
accused of this made that promise of
money for sex before anything happened
yeah I guess the big question I have and
certainly if I'm Robert Crabb
you know I'm not going to jail I can pay
a fine and you know like you know maybe
I can get this expunged from my record
this is all about that video Mike
whether he's guilty or not that video of
surfacing would be what I would have
sleepless nights if I'm Robert Kraft is
there any way to keep that video from
being released publicly well they're
going to try their damnedest to do it
and that's where a court order would get
involved to permanently seal the records
and then if somebody from law
enforcement would leak it they'd be
facing serious personal criminal
penalties if it would be proven that
they did this is far different from a
security guard at a hotel that went out
of business selling the Ray Rice
elevator video to TMZ if the court says
this shall never be released and I think
that gives it an extra layer of
protection so the other concern is this
to dance if he pleads guilty to anything
then he walks right into a a suspension
and and and the question that I keep
coming back to if he's fully exonerated
for this right if it's thrown out if
it's dismissed if there's never any
violation if there's a diversion program
guilty plea no contest anything what
does the Commissioner do because if it
was a player yeah under these
allegations I don't think the
Commissioner would do anything if you
get no no sanction of any kind if you
just walk away with a dismissal or an
acquittal at trial but since it's
another you know we're here all the time
they're held to a higher standard
if a player would be securing a
dismissal subject to nothing what does
an owner get subjected to if he ends up
securing a full dismissal or a full
exoneration that's going to be the real
question for for the commissioner when
the dust settles on this if Kraft wins
it thank you Mike
appreciate your time as always all right
but that's Mike Florio pro football talk
comm pro football talk live in the NBC
Sports Network for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show at
you